Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritler und
grüße alle hier zur Ausgabe Nummer vierundfünfzig und auch diese ist, wie sollte es anders sein, die wöchentliche Ausgabe rund um die Koronakrise
Corona Weekly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Ja, der achte Januar, da hatten wir gesagt, vor einer Woche und ich glaube auch vor zwei Wochen.
So der Termin wo wir vielleicht ein bisschen Klarheit bekommen können ähm.
Was denn jetzt eigentlich so Phase ist. Ich habe so den Eindruck so ganz sind wir noch nicht da, aber Dinge zeichnen sich äh.
Ja, das ist äh richtig. Ähm.
Was man sagen kann ist es über Weihnachten wohl nichts Schlimmes passiert ist,
Silvester wissen wir noch nicht so genau. Aber ähm ja.
Die Zahlen sind halt extrem mit Vorsicht zu genießen, die jetzt jeden Tag vermeldet werden ähm und.
Das ist weil einfach äh die Testzahlen massiv eingebrochen sind. Also das immer im Hinterkopf behalten. Wir haben,
nämlich in der letzten Woche gerade mal siebenhundertneunzigtausend Tests durchgeführt. Das ist,
halb so viel wie Ende November. Also in den und vor allem in den letzten beiden Wochen sind die eben massiv eingebrochen. Äh so die Zahl.
Tests aus verschiedensten Gründen und wenn da natürlich weniger getestet wird, dann kann man natürlich auch weniger finden, so das heißt äh die Dunkelsiffer ist äh gestiegen,
und ähm ja trotzdem.
Haben wir äh heute einen neuen Tageshöchstwert bei Toten und ähm.
Der sieben Tage Schnitt steigt jetzt auch wieder erstmals seit zwei Wochen. So wir hatten also einen einen Rückgang ungefähr äh auf das ja vor Weihnachtsniveau.
Ähm so äh während wir eben dann ja diesen Partner.
Und vor etwa ja zwei bis drei Wochen waren die Zahlen so auf dem Höhepunkt,
sind seitdem eben wieder auf Vorweihnachtsniveau gefallen, aber es sind eben nur die Zahlen und äh die untererfassen eben im Moment, das tatsächliche,
Infektionsgeschehen, aber trotz dieser Untererfassung des Infektionsgeschehens liegt jetzt der sieben Tage R bei null Komma neun acht. Das heißt,
faktisch ja sind die Zahlen zwar noch ein bisschen gesunken in den letzten sieben Tagen gegenüber den sieben Tagen davor, aber nur noch minimal.
Und ähm das sind aber nur die Zahlen, das heißt, wir können sagen, die Infektionstätigkeit, beziehungsweise,
die Infektion breitet sich wieder aus, langsam, zwar aber die Zahlen gingen definitiv nicht mehr zurück. So und sind auch nicht so stark zurückgegangen,
wie es jetzt die Zahlen vermitteln, also die die tatsächliche äh tatsächlichen Infektion.
Das lässt sich ja vor allem an der positiven Quote immer ganz gut ablesen, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist die so hoch, wie sie noch nie war.
Mit sechzehn Komma null sieben,
Prozent. Und es ist eigentlich ist so ein Blick auf die positiven Quote, kann man sagen.
Ähnelt äh sehr stark halt der ähm infiziert.
Also das kann man fast, wenn man ähm die positiven Quote statt die Institut sieht das Ganze eben ähm ja sehr ähnlich aus.
Und ähm ja damit kann man eben auch so ein bisschen die,
sozusagen Korrekturfaktor für die Zahl der Testungen äh auch. Wobei das halt schwierig zu äh genau zu quantifizieren ist, wie stark die Auswirkungen sind. Da gibt's zwar Modelle, aber
ja
das zu kalibrieren jeweils ist halt nicht ganz einfach, weil sich ja auch nicht nur ändert äh wie getestet wird, sondern zum Teil auch wer getestet wird und so, das heißt.
Man ähm kann da eher nur so Tendenzen angeben. Und Tendenz ist ähm es steigt weiter.
Guckt man jetzt nur auf die positiven Quote, kann man sagen, es ist nie gefallen.
Ja. Jetzt vielleicht nochmal, um das so ein bisschen in Kontext zu setzen,
die Testzahlen, die du jetzt also niedrig an ähm gereidet hast, was ja sind, ne? Also wir hatten in der,
bezieht sich jetzt auf die KW dreiundfünfzig und wir hatten ja auch schon letzte Woche mit dem Blick auf die KW zweiundfünfzig ein äh Einbruch so, also war's einundfünfzig noch relativ.
Hoch, also hatten wir sozusagen in der KW einundfünfzig, sprich vor Weihnachten äh mit tausendsechshundertzwölf Tests, den höchsten Testwert, den wir überhaupt bisher hatten.
Ist er dann relativ schnell ähm also,
Vielleicht mal um das deutlich zu machen, KW einundfünfzig gingen bis zum zwanzigsten Dezember, ja? Also da war dann richtig viel Alarm,
Ich vermute auch mal, da dürften sich auch allein deshalb mehr Leute getestet haben, weil sie alle so oh Gott, Weihnachten, ich muss mich jetzt mal testen,
dann kam halt Weihnachten KW zweiundfünfzig ging am einundzwanzigsten Dezember los und erstreckte sich eben bis zum,
siebenundzwanzigsten, also da ist jetzt so das vollständige Weihnachtsgeschehen schon mal mit äh oder zumindest das Vorweihnachts- und Hauptweihnachtsgeschehen äh drin.
Da waren wir dann schon auf eine Million runter, also mal so locker, sechshunderttausend weniger.
Und jetzt halt nochmal zwei äh ja zweihundertzehntausend weniger.
In KW dreiundfünfzig, sprich vom achtundzwanzigsten Dezember bis zum dritten Januar.
Ja, ich habe übrigens jetzt die Prozentrechnung äh in,
Bildern äh so korrigiert, dass äh er, wenn's nach oben geht, nimm da,
sagen den unteren Wert äh als Ausgangspunkt und wenn's äh runtergegangen ist äh hinter den ja äh größeren äh Wert. Nur weil wir äh beim letzten, in der letzten Sendung,
diese fünfzig Versus dreißig Prozent hatten als sie.
Heißt, du kannst sagen, ist jetzt sozusagen erst um dreiunddreißig Komma fünf und dann nochmal um sechsundzwanzig Prozent gefallen äh seit der KW einundfünfzig.
Genau, so was was sagt uns das jetzt, dass wir wahrscheinlich noch so ein Weihnachtsnachweihnachtsüberhang haben. So viele Leute,
haben sicherlich die Zeit zwischen Weihnachten und neue Jahr
benutzt, um sozusagen da zu bleiben, wo sie waren. Erstmal was Gutes. Ja und hatten relativ wenig äh äh Lust und Motivation, sich testen zu lassen und das hat dann eben zu diesem krassen,
Testeinbruch geführt mit anderen Worten, es wäre meine Erwartung, dass wir jetzt in KW eins eine enorme Test,
an einen enormen Testanstieg sehen. Bis zu einer Verdoppelung.
Ja das sollte eigentlich so sein. Ähm aber ja wir werden sehen.
Wir werden sehen. Tja, was machen wir jetzt da draus? Also.
Was liest du daraus? Also bedeutet das, dass die Leute sich Weihnachten doch irgendwie bisschen zurückgehalten haben.
Ja, also ähm ich meine, es sind sind ja quasi über Weihnachten, sind halt mehrere Dinge zusammengekommen. Einmal.
Schulen zu Geschäfte zu und auch Büros zu.
Ja das äh hat natürlich sicher äh auf die Ausbreitung gedrückt, also die Ausbreitung nach unten gedrückt.
Auf der anderen Seite gab's dann eben mehr private äh Kontakte,
die die Ausbreitung äh ja nach oben getrieben haben. Es scheint jetzt so zu sein, äh dass sich diese beiden Effekte die Waage gehalten haben.
So in etwa, kann man sagen, wobei wir das eben genauer erst dann nächste Woche wissen, äh werden, weil wir es jetzt nur für Weihnachten sagen können und ähm ja äh.
Das heißt ja dann im Prinzip auch das Infektionsgeschehen hat nicht wirklich abgenommen, es hat sich nur verlagert.
Ja, es hat sich entweder verlagert oder äh wenn wir dann jetzt sehen, wenn jetzt wieder Normalität,
einkehrt. So, wenn jetzt also wieder die Leute arbeiten gehen und leider auch zu wenige in Home-Office ist, also viel weniger als im im April äh arbeiten im Moment im im Homeoffice, das ist halt auch so ein.
Thema ähm ja äh,
wenn das also jetzt jetzt wieder äh wieder passiert, dann äh plus die privaten Kontakte aber wegfallen, je nachdem was, welcher Effekt jetzt stärker war
Möglicherweise werden jetzt in der nächsten Woche dann die Zahlen steigen oder fallen,
so oder weiter gleich bleiben äh was.
Ja auch wahrscheinlich ist, aber ich erwarte tendenziell äh eher wieder steigende äh Zahlen,
bestenfalls gleichbleibende.
Gut, ich meine, das ist aber der Moment, wo man dann sich vielleicht einfach nochmal den Verlauf der Todeszahlen anschauen sollte und da ist es ja auch ein bisschen ruhiert, weil wir hatten.
Dann ähm über Weihnachten auch geringere Todeszahlen, also Meldungen, da kann man sagen, okay, das ist dann wahrscheinlich wirklich die verzögerte Meldung dessen,
Ist nicht so, dass die Leute dann auch auf einmal nicht sterben, weil irgendein besonderes Datum ist,
Wenn ich mir die Kurve so anschaue, dann geht die ja eigentlich noch kontinuierlich nach oben. Sprich, wenn man das sozusagen.
Äh mal daraus extra poliert, hat sich eigentlich nicht viel verbessert.
Also heute gab's halt einen deutlichen Sprung wieder nach oben, ja und.
Auch ähm wenn wir jetzt zu Berlin gehen, wo ich mir das äh.
Halt genauer angesehen habe.
Dann äh ist die Belegung der Krankenhäuser und Intensivstationen, was ja auch immer so ein relativ direktes Ding äh,
ist so, wenn's den Leuten schlecht geht, äh halt und da ist kein Rückgang zu verzeichnen, sondern eben auch äh sowas, es gab einen,
leichten Rückgang bei den stationären
Aufnahmen so seit zwei Wochen beziehungsweise über ähm ja nach Weihnachten gab's da einen kleinen Peak. Seitdem ändert sich da nicht viel und auch die Intensivstationsbelegung
wächst nicht mehr so stark, aber geht auch nicht zurück. So, das heißt äh auch,
diese Zahlen zumindest in in Berlin zeigen, dass da jetzt nichts runtergegangen ist zumindest, sondern.
Dass wir jetzt eine Stagnation gesehen haben der Zahlen.
Ja, es geht einfach nach oben, kann man einfach mal sagen, also jetzt ist es eskaliert nicht total, super exponentiell nach oben, aber es ist einfach steigende Zahlen behängt fertig.
Also je nachdem wie weit man jetzt jetzt guckt, aber äh,
kann sagen, es geht definitiv nichts nach unten, es steigt halt weniger stark an oder bleibt ungefähr auf gleichem Niveau, je nachdem wo man hinguckt, aber,
sagt überall sowohl in Berlin als auch äh im im Bund,
heute, also mit dem Tag heute 'nen,
größerer Anstieg wieder auf eigentlich das Niveau von vor Weihnachten so jetzt Freitagszahlen mit Freitagszahlen verglichen.
Genau, heute im Übrigen, der achte Januar, äh, machen wir wieder vergessen, zu erwähnen. Ja, mhm.
Genau und eine positive Quote sogar noch leicht höher als im Bund, also hier ist auf jeden Fall was los,
die alte Regel mit Berlin schreitet voran neben dann sieht es auch nicht gut aus.
Ähm, vielleicht aber bevor wir Berlin reingehen, äh, auch nochmal.
Mit 'n Blick auf den Ländervergleich der Risikokabelle und da ist auch immer ganz gut zu gucken OK.
Wenn man den gesamten Deutschlandwert.
Nimmt und guckt, wie sich das so auf die Bundesländer verteilt und wo es zum Beispiel äh inwiefern Bundesländer die Zahlen steigen oder fallen, dann äh war da ganz klar einen Trend zu
beobachten, äh dass wir zwischenzeitlich hatten wir fast überall fallende Zahlen,
jetzt äh sind es äh bereits wieder sieben Bundesländer, in denen die Zahlen gestiegen sind,
in den letzten sieben Tagen im Vergleich zu den sieben Tagen davor.
Und ja Sachsen äh ist ähm nach wie vor vorne beim Risiko, wobei äh ja und und auch bei der Institanz.
Aber noch leicht fallend beziehungsweise stabil.
Und ansonsten haben wir Brandenburgs Sachsen-Anhalt und Berlin.
Das sind die vorderen fünf alle im Osten gelegen. Einzig Mecklenburg-Vorpommern von den Ostländern.
Ist bei der Insidenz.
Am Ende der Tabelle, aber auch da steigen die Zahlen wieder und steigen sogar gerade am stärksten. So, aber gut, das sind immer so Pendel und Auf und Abbewegungen, aber.
Das Muster ist äh so eigentlich Ostdeutschland und Bayern. Ah und Hamburg ist auch wieder im Kommen. So, die waren eigentlich mal ganz unten und Bremen, Tabellenletzter, was in diesem Fall vielleicht eine gute.
Sache ist. Ähm.
Meine, was ich da so ein bisschen rauslese, ist, wir hatten ja nun vor ähm zwei, drei Wochen, als es so mit Sachsen richtig losging.
Dem ging ja im Prinzip dieser krasse Ausbruch in Tschechien auch voraus.
Die werden wir sicherlich nachher nochmal drauf kommen mittlerweile äh auch die Kurve wieder äh in die falsche Richtung genommen haben und nochmal richtig zugelegt haben. Ähm das heißt.
Ich sage nicht, das kommt jetzt aus Tschechien, aber es ist halt einfach so.
Eine Ausbreitung ist eine lokale Geschichte und die macht jetzt so vor Ländergrenzen nur bedingt halt, es sei denn, du machst sie, machst die halt so richtig komplett zu und das hat ja nie stattgefunden
So, dann hat sie sich in Sachsen angedickt, dann war's äh letzte Woche schon hat's sich abgezeichnet, dass es eben zunehmende Maße auch in Brandenburg und zwar in Südbrandenburg reingeht
und in Sachsen-Anhalt und jetzt äh macht es so den Eindruck, als ob's
quasi weiter nach Norden läuft durch Berlin äh und auch schon so langsam Mecklenburg-Vorpommern anfasst. Und das,
jetzt noch ganz subjektive Betrachtung, aber das das denke ich mal, geben die Zahlen schon ein wenig her. Ne, also selbst wenn die insgesamt alle noch nicht aussagekräftig sind, also nicht wirklich das Geschehen
ab deutlich abbilden, sieht man halt schon so ein so ein Südnord Trend.
Ja und es wabert auch ganz krass so durch Brandenburg äh äh durch, so da sagen da gehen die.
Ausbrüche so von einem Landkreis, zum anderen im Moment ist gerade Frankfurt oder,
der Spitzenlandkreis einfach, weil sich dort auch in den letzten in der letzten Woche, äh, letzten sieben Tagen die Infektion verdreifacht haben.
Da sind wahrscheinlich auch Nachmeldungen dabei, eine ganze Menge. So, aber nichtsdestotrotz, außerdem mit einer Institanz äh dann von ja dreihundertvierundfünfzig.
Und das ist halt auch einfach hoch und dann andere Brandenburger Landkreise, also Elbe, Elster, Ostprignitz, Rupin, Spree-Neiße, Dame, Spreewald, Potsdam, Mittelmark, alle in den Top dreißig.
Also die Top dreißig sind praktisch ostdeutsche Landkreise plus dreimal Bayern plus einmal Hessen. Ja.
Also so sieht es äh gerade in der Fläche aus.
Also während die erste Welle vor allem von Süd und Westdeutschland dominiert war, geht jetzt Pokal langsam in den Osten rüber. Da war noch Nachholpotenzial.
Gibt's denn so Berlin noch speziell was zu berichten?
Ja, also äh.
Ein ganz spezielles äh Thema äh wir haben ja auch immer die Institenz in den Altersgruppen äh angeschaut und.
Da gibt es heute eine besondere Auffälligkeit, was.
Noch was noch immer leider so ist, wie es war, ist das äh die ähm Altersgruppe achtzig Plus, die mit weitem am stärkste.
Institenz hat.
Aber was jetzt ganz neu ist, ist das ähm ja in den letzten drei, vier Wochen.
Die Institenz in den Altersgruppen, ja ich sage mal fünf bis vierzehn und,
fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig auch gefallen ist, aber ganz speziell, wenn man sich das dann nochmal genauer anguckt, so die Altersgruppe fünf bis Neunzehnjährigen, also die Schüler.
Da sind die Inzidenzen extrem zurückgegangen und bei den zehn bis Vierzehnjährigen sogar auf ein Fünftel dessen, äh wo es Anfang Dezember noch war. Also ja,
Das ist natürlich sehr krass. Ist sicherlich auch mit,
verzerrt durch Tests, aber das ist nicht alleine aufs Testen zurückzuführen. Das kann ich mir beim besten,
Wenn mich vorstellen ähm und.
Das äh bedeutet halt, dass es so aussieht, dass der Beitrag der Schüler.
Zur Ausbreitung der Infektion viel viel größer zu sein, scheint oder gewesen zu sein, scheint, als wir das ähm.
So wahrhaben wollten oder viele das äh wahrhaben wollten äh und,
dass gerade vor dem Hintergrund jetzt der Debatte, dass plötzlich überraschend angekündigt werden würde, dass halt.
Schulen teilweise jetzt schon zeitnah geöffnet werden sollen. Ich glaube sogar ab Montag,
schon sollen irgendwo Tests äh äh stattfinden, ist alles so ein bisschen noch unklar und intransparent, aber es sollen wieder äh vermehrt Schüler in Schulen gehen. So habe ich das.
Ja, also wie es aus, also ich habe ja wieder so zwei Schulen als äh Sample, da ich zwei äh Kids in der Schule habe
da ist es halt so normaler Unterricht, nein, aber Klassenarbeiten. Also sie wollen halt die Kids äh zumindest für die Klassenarbeiten, die geschrieben werden sollen, dann nochmal äh.
Ne, so für eine Stunde oder zwei in äh Aulas sitzen, da werden dann auch nochmal die Klassen nochmal halbiert und so.
Weil sonst würden die Schüler ja, könnten ja sonst betrügen. Wenn ihr es nicht.
Ja gut, ich.
Wenn die nicht.
Klassenarbeit mit Internetanschluss ist nicht so ganz Sinn der Sache. Ähm ja, da kann man jetzt drüber äh diskutieren. Ich denke.
Was jetzt was jetzt nicht angemessen wäre, wäre halt eine vollständige Öffnung Normalbetrieb der Schulen,
und ich bin jetzt gerade auch ein bisschen verwirrt und auch ein wenig durcheinander gebracht worden durch diese ganzen äh Habab, der da in den USA abgeht, dass ich so ein bisschen meinen Blick von den von der Nachrichtenlage genommen habe, aber.
Der ähm Politikkonsens äh scheint auch zu sein, im Prinzip die Schulen jetzt erstmal bis Ende des Monats geschlossen zu lassen oder habe ich da was äh verpasst?
Eigentlich ja aber in äh Berlin äh hat dann plötzlich kam dann aus dem Schulsenat,
Ankündigungen, die,
eigentlich erstmal im Widerspruch zu dem, was sowohl was Müller am Tag vorher gesagt hat, als auch was das Ergebnis der Ministerpräsidentenrunde,
war. Aber vermutlich haben wir alle das Kleingedruckte äh nicht gelesen, äh die dann äh das bestimmt dann irgendwelche Ausnahmeregelungen
ermöglicht für bestimmte Jahrgangsstufen wie zum Beispiel für Prüfungen oder so. Und äh deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, dass man zumindest in Berlin versucht die
möglichen Ausnahmeregelungen, soweit es geht auszuschöpfen. Ja.
Zumindest eben für Klassenarbeiten.
Wie auch immer aber das war so ein bisschen der,
Eindruck und äh gerade ist auch noch lasst die Schulen und Kitas zu. Ist äh immer noch Trending äh auf Twitter. Äh das Hashtag weil da gab es da doch äh heute halt,
sehr viel Unmut äh auch bei Eltern.
Ja, da gehen auch schon die ersten Petitionen rum. Mhm.
Und und auch einzelne Schulen, die gesagt haben, da machen wir nicht mit.
In Berlin, also das ist wohl heute so ist da der Unmut aufgeflammt und,
kann das auch total nachvollziehen, weil äh ich habe das heute äh auch versucht in einem Tweet auf den Punkt zu bringen ähm.
So ich möchte auch gerne das alles wieder normal ist, dass alles wieder
auf ist äh so, dass äh ja, meinetwegen klar auch die Schulen wieder auf äh sind, dass die Läden wieder auf sind, dass sich wieder in einem Restaurant sitzen kann, sich wieder in ein Museum gehen,
kann und es sich tausend andere Sachen die ich gerne machen würde wieder machen kann. So aber,
das ist jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Lockerungen abhängig oder ob die auf oder zu machen, weil.
Wenn jetzt die Kneipen offen wär, ich würde da trotzdem nicht hingehen, weil gerade jeder achtzigste im Moment,
mit dem Virus infiziert ist in Berlin und praktisch. Ich in jedem Supermarkt, in jeder Schule, in jedem größeren Innenraum, in jeder Bahn äh so.
Sitzt jemand, der hat halt eine Kopie von dem Virus und bei dem kann ich mich anstecken, ja? Das heißt.
Lockerungen nützen mir gar nichts. Sie haben.
Keine Auswirkung auf mein Leben, solange die Zahlen noch hoch sind. Das Einzige.
Was Lockerungen im Moment bewirken oder auch ausgebliebene Verschärfung ist, dass sich halt länger warten muss, dass ich halt länger äh äh.
Auf meine Freiheit warten muss länger in diesem Zustand verweilen muss. Also äh deswegen ja äh können sich unsere Regierenden gerade die Lockerungen sonst wohin stecken.
Das äh äh ja, das ist einfach nur Kontraproduktiv, sogar die ganze Debatte macht mich einfach nur wütend. So, es ist einfach nur verantwortungslos,
was äh da passiert. Sowohl die Debatte als auch irgendwie diese Entscheidungen. So und.
Da bin ich halt mittlerweile auch ganz knallhart, so jedes einzelne Loch, jede einzelne äh.
Öffnung, die zu mehr Begegnungen äh führt, so ist.
Nicht gut. Und das mit den Klassenarbeiten, ey, was soll denn das.
Es ist ja nicht nur, dass sie dann in der Schule zusammensitzen, sondern auch noch davor und danach und dann natürlich auch nicht einsehen, warum sie nicht auch am Nachmittag,
irgendwie zusammen sitzen sollen. Das äh führt dann auch nur wieder zum diese ganzen Ausnahmen zum äh äh Unterlaufen und zu weniger Akzeptanz, weil die Leute sagen, das ist auch unlogisch,
warum soll ich warum muss ich irgendwie ins Büro oder in die U-Bahn oder das und darf mich dann nicht äh mehr.
Freunden treffen oder Freunde zu Hause einladen, so das ist auch überhaupt nicht einzusehen, ja? Und das,
kapieren die auch nicht, aber faktisch ist auch jede einzelne Ansteckung,
ist halt ein Problem. In China, weiß nicht, ob das äh mitgekriegt hast, Fehlverteilung halt verblockt. Da hatten sie jetzt einen Ausbruch.
Größeren äh zweihundert Fälle haben sie in einer Stadt,
äh äh gefunden. Ja, das ist äh so, dass es bei denen größerer Ausbruch. Wie haben sie reagiert? Die haben,
die komplette Stadt mit zwölf Millionen Einwohnern komplett in den Logdown geschickt, testen die Bevölkerung, zwölf Millionen komplett durch.
Und äh sind da fest entschlossen einfach äh ja ähm Schulen sind zu.
In China, wenn da in der Stadt zweihundert Fälle auftreten bei bei zwölf Millionen.
Es ist äh und.
Also zum Vergleich Berlin hatte sechstausenddreihundert Fälle letzten sieben Tagen.
So, ja und äh.
Drittel so groß?
Ne?
Und ich meine das ist, es halt, es ist halt wirklich peinlich äh einfach nur auch so Chinesen teilweise, wie die das sehen oder darauf reagieren, was hier los sind. Die denken, wir sind einfach komplett verrückt, was wir hier machen,
denken, wir sind einfach nur bekloppt.
Lässt sich auch nicht ganz von der Hand weisen, denke ich.
Will. Nee. Nee. Und ja, ich finde und äh ja und ich mag das persönlich auch nicht äh so von Chinesen für bekloppt gehalten äh zu werden. Äh so.
Ja gut, ich meine, damit komme ich noch klar, aber das hat mir ja zumindest recht.
Ja, Bodo Ramelow, der äh Ministerpräsident von Thüringen, der ist ja jetzt irgendwie an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen und hat zumindest mal zugegeben, dass er falsch lag. Das finde ich ja schon mal ein ganz ganz interessanten Move, ne.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist äh ich meine, spät aber immerhin.
Aber äh so meine Reaktion war halt auch ey die ganze Kacke hätten wir uns doch sparen können, wenn diese Einsicht.
Vielleicht mal zwei Monate früher gekommen wäre.
So, dann äh wäre die Situation jetzt eine ganz andere.
Wenn wir da einfach mal dicht gemacht hätten für einen Monat, so, dann ja ähm wäre zwar auch nicht alles jetzt normal und tutti.
So, dafür hätten wir im Sommer äh einfach nur,
richtig handeln müssen aber ja das musste alles nicht sein und das muss nicht sein, wo wir jetzt äh sind und äh interessanterweise.
Ja, kam ja wohl sogar jetzt mittlerweile was von Wirtschaftsverbänden. Äh die äh langsam einsehen, dass äh das so nicht weitergeht, dass äh wir da was tun müssen.
Ja, ja, also der der Druck kommt, ne? Weil natürlich alle sehen, dass dieses fortwährende Rumeiern äh eigentlich letzten Endes noch sehr viel mehr Geld kostet und vor allem im Hinblick auf,
den erlösenden April oder so oder Mai, ja, wo wir so perspektivisch in einer optimalen Entwicklung ja schon gesagt haben.
Das könnte so der Zeitpunkt sein, wo der Scheiß dann so langsam von uns wegfällt, ne, dass dass jetzt einfach weiter verschleppt wird.
Also die Welle, die wir jetzt haben, ist einmal Vielfaches, stärker als das, was wir äh Anfang letzten Jahres bekämpft haben.
Und das bedeutet, sie wird auch längere Zeit.
Auswirkungen haben, mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass halt einfach tausend Hute pro Tag jetzt einfach noch die nächsten Wochen der das absolute Minimum sein werden. Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir da
ab den nächsten zwei Wochen irgendwie nennenswert niedrigere Zahlen sehen werden als das.
Ja. Also alles ähm sehr, sehr unbefriedigend, sehr, sehr unbefriedigend und.
Dazu kommt noch, dass dass eben einfach auch das haben wir ja nun auch schon mehrfach gesagt, ne? Dadurch, dass man eben äh Soft einsteigt und jetzt immer so ein bisschen versucht, nachzulegen.
Da natürlich die Maßnahmen auch gegenseitig in die Quere kommen, weil einfach die Akzeptanz äh natürlich nicht da ist
hätte man halt einfach von vornherein gesagt, jetzt machen wir nochmal so richtig hart und dann schauen wir mal, wenn's gut ist, dann lockern wir aber auch erst, wenn's wirklich richtig gut ist
vielleicht noch nicht mal so stark und dann
wird's halt zumindest immer besser und derzeit ist es halt genau das Gegenteil, ja? Ah ja, nee, hat nichts gebracht. Jetzt müssen wir nochmal einen drauflegen, dann nehmen wir einen drauf und dann
ist aber immer noch nicht besser, weil sich's natürlich in der Zwischenzeit weiter verschlimmert hat und noch härtere Maßnahmen machen könntest und wer jetzt an so einem Punkt angekommen sind, wo irgendwie außer.
Jetzt der der erste Lokdown, der den Namen verdient. Ja so, wenn der müsste jetzt im Prinzip kommen, der macht überhaupt niemanden mehr Spaß,
Also so war's 'ne in der Kategorie von niemand geht jetzt mehr raus außer vielleicht Wasserwerk, Elektrizitätswerk und also so, ne? Die absolut,
unverzichtbaren Berufe und äh alle anderen bleiben wirklich in der Wohnung.
Und es ist jetzt auch alles ja keine Überraschung. Ich meine, kann ja jetzt wahrscheinlich die Sendungen mal nachhören oder nachgucken, so wann wir darüber geredet äh haben äh.
Aber das war ja mit Sicherheit schon im Oktober, wo wir gesagt haben, das äh geht so nicht, da müssen wir halt jetzt da muss jetzt eigentlich ein massiver, harter Lokdown äh.
Und denn ja.
Und im Sommer, wenn man weiter zurück geht, war halt auch schon in den Monaten davor klar, äh als es so langsam hochkochte und immer mehr wurde, äh war eigentlich klar, dass das so nicht weitergehen,
kann äh dauerhaft, dass der Herbst kommt. Ich meine, der Herbst war bekannt, dass der Herbst kommt im Frühjahr schon. So.
Was soll man noch dazu sagen eigentlich? Also es macht ja eigentlich auch für dich jetzt gar keinen Spaß die ganze Zeit sich immer nur zu wiederholen und äh den besser besser raushängen zu lassen ne.
Ja und dieses Soldie so äh.
Macht auch keinen Spaß.
Alles kein Spaß Plus. Ach so, was mir noch ein für Südafrika äh sagt es in Südafrika haben wir nicht nur die neue Variante, sondern da gehen die Zahlen auch gerade massiv in die Höhe.
Wobei halt Südafrika ja gerade Sommer hat.
Das heißt, äh, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das an der Virusvariante liegt oder am Wetter oder an anderen äh Faktoren, aber ähm,
Ich meine, wenn das, was da abgeht
sagen im Sommer abgeht, können wir vielleicht uns auch abschminken, weil ich finde das halt ist das halt eine spezielle Sommervirusvariante, die halt ein bisschen ähm hitzefester ist,
zu Hulas. Ähm ja,
Und die ist da jetzt auch schon bei uns. So kann man äh halt auch von ausgehen so plus die UK-Variante plus. Ähm.
Dass äh die potenziell ähm nicht alle Impfstoffe funktionieren mit der UK Variation. Äh mit der ähm.
Da können wir gleich mal drauf,
eingehen vielleicht mal um dieses ganze Maßnahmending und was hätte man eigentlich besser machen können oder was könnte man noch besser machen, abzuschließen. Ähm gibt ja ein paar interessante Vorschläge auch.
Unter anderem dieses Konzept von ähm Green Zones, das ist so quasi die harte Lokdown Strategie,
Kann man sich nachschlagen auf äh Endcorona Varus äh dot org, so die Green Zone Exits Strategie, die halt einfach sagt so,
Ihr macht jetzt hier einfach so lange irgendwie alle Grenzen so richtig schön dicht. So und ihr dürft nur dann eine Grenze aufmachen, wenn halt Green Zone ist, also wenn sozusagen,
da am Start ist und klar, das klingt hier alles immer noch so ein bisschen fern
auf der Webseite finden sich dann auch immer schöne aktuelle Grafiken wo dann die Länder aufgelistet sind, die das derzeit sehr wohl hinbekommen.
Länder, die mehr oder weniger auf dem Weg dahin äh zu sein, scheinen, ja, auch wenn es nicht garantiert ist und die Länder
die halt gerade äh ja wie heißt es so schön Countrys, that Netotake Action. Da sind wir jetzt mittlerweile auch äh vertreten in diesem Bereich, auch wenn wir da zwischenzeitlich, glaube ich, mal in dem
könnt ihr noch hinhauen waren. Das aber jetzt eben nicht mehr der Fall und ja das,
Markt mal jetzt für Leute, die darüber nachdenken, was man denn eigentlich tun äh möchte und welche Ziele man sich vor allem setzt. Das ist ja auch das, was mich so stört die ganze Zeit, dass einfach keine Ziele genannt werden.
Und wenn Ziele genannt werden, dann ist es so, ja, was haben wir jetzt wieder gehabt mit äh irgendwie auf eine Inszenz von zweihundert runterkommen.
Nochmal.
Zweihundert war die Grenze für die fünfzehn Kilometer äh ähm Sperrzone äh oder Bewegungsbeschränkungen.
Ja, zweihundert. Also wir hatten irgendwann mal fünfzig so und alle Experten sagen irgendwie bevor wir nicht auf fünfundzwanzig sind,
brauchen wir irgendwie gar nicht weiter zu diskutieren. So und das ist ja noch nicht mal die Sirokowit Nummer, sondern es hat bedeutet, dass man immer wieder Infektionsherde hat und so. Aber ich glaube.
Der Zug ist auch abgefahren,
Also wir kriegen das offensichtlich in Europa nicht hin. Ist ja noch nicht mal so, dass jetzt irgendein europäisches Land gäbe, wo man drauf zeigen kann und sagen kann, so, ah, guck mal hier, die sind ja hier der totale Vorreiter.
Finnland, vielleicht Finnland ähm kriegt's irgendwie hin äh.
Ja. Finnland ist derzeit auch im roten Bereich auf äh in Corona Walross äh Aktion. Also das.
Das das ist generell nicht gut in Europa. Also es ist einfach die Infektionslage ist derzeit einfach überall zu groß. Es ist,
es ist so hoch, dass man einfach gar nichts unter Kontrolle hat, dass man mit dem Test nicht hinterherkommt
dass man schon gar nicht mit dem Contact Racing hinterherkommt, das ist einfach, es läuft einfach alles komplett aus dem Ruder und ja, das bringt halt,
neue Gefahren mit sich. Und damit sind wir ein bisschen bei dieser Variantendiskussion.
Hatten wir ja hier auch schon, also gerade die Situation in äh.
Großbritannien oder ganz konkret auch vor allem in Südengland zeigt, dass halt Non-Action einfach neue Probleme schafft.
Weil mal ganz davon abgesehen, also selbst wenn man sich sagen könnte, so na ja, die paar Toten, ja,
kriegen wir jetzt irgendwie auch noch äh äh weg, so hier so Boris Palma mäßig, die werden ja sowieso gestorben, sterben sie halt ein bisschen früher, Hukas
Bild zum Zynismus könnte man natürlich daran gehen. Das Problem ist nur, oder auch generell so diese ganze Herdenimonitätsgequatsche. Das war ja auch,
am Anfang in UK ein Thema, das hat äh Schweden auch auf eine böse Spur gebracht et cetera.
Den Virus sich nicht äh zu stark einzutreten, hat ja auch noch ein paar andere Vorteile. Und einer davon ist, umso weniger Instellenz man hat, umso weniger Mutationspotenzial gibt es.
Und jetzt haben wir halt verschiedene Varianten und verschiedene Änderungen, wo die Wissenschaft auch gerade immer noch ein wenig am Rätseln ist. Was äh denn nun die Konsequenz davon ist.
Glaub ich hatte das letzte Mal hier auch schon so aufgeführt, dass es immer noch so ein Disconnect gibt zwischen,
Konkreter virologischer Erkenntnis, was denn nun bitte mit diesen Varianten eigentlich wirklich anders ist, dass sie besser funktionieren, ja? Versus dem immer stärker werdenden Epidemiologischen Befund,
dass man einfach sagen kann wir können euch das hier zwar jetzt virologisch noch nicht erklären aber wir sehen einfach die Zahlen und die,
Stärke, mit der sich diese Varianten durchsetzen ist mit so klassischen,
epidomöologischen Effekten wie diesem Foundereffekt, also dass eine bestimmte Virusvariante mehr oder weniger durch Zufall gerade äh Teil von Superspreadern Events geworden ist und in einer,
Ja, so einer nativen Gesellschaft sich einfach durchgesetzt hat und dadurch eben einfach dominant geworden ist,
ohne dass die Variante selber einen biochemischen Vorsprung hat und,
Es ist für mich ein bisschen schwer zu scannen, was so derzeit die allgemeinen vorherrschende Meinung dazu ist. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, die Virologen können zwar derzeit noch nicht erklären, was da wirklich jetzt genau technisch anders ist.
Aber sie akzeptieren zumindest diesenologischen Befund, dass diese Variante sich besser durchsetzt. Ja,
sieht man, wir haben explodierende Infektionszahlen eben in äh England, wir haben mittlerweile auch relativ starke Infektionsausbrüche in Irland,
Balla habe nicht die einzigen Länder, die von starken Ausbrüchen begleitet sind, auch,
Das Geschehen in Tschechien ist nach wie vor krass, ja? Und auch ist immer, ich finde das immer so absurd, wenn dann so auf Twitter so, ja, hier, guck mal, you cay, die letzten drei Wochen und dann hast du halt so diese Kurve, die so nach oben geht, ne? Warum muss das dann schon mal in Relation setzen?
Schon mal schauen, okay, aber was haben wir denn so bisher gehabt, ne? Und dann kann man halt auch immer wieder sagen.
Ja okay, das sieht zwar jetzt mal ganz fit aus, so aber legst du jetzt mal Belgien vom von von März zwanzig zwanzig dann eben, das ist immer noch nichts dagegen,
Ja, also es ist einfach so der der Ausbruch in in Belgien schlägt nach wie vor alles. Auch die neuen Varianten et cetera. Das muss nicht so bleiben. Aber es ist zumindest so. Also nur aus ähm,
aus so einer Momentaufnahme heraus kann man jetzt hier noch nicht sagen.
Da kommt uns jetzt der Virus irgendwie hart rein, sondern es hat einfach im Wesentlichen was damit zu tun, wie man darauf reagiert,
Das ist sicherlich in England nicht gut gelaufen. Wir haben halt auch so ein Government, was irgendwie heute hü, morgen Hot sagt und keiner weiß Bescheid. Also wenn wir uns über unsere Politik beklagen, ja, dann ist es einfach noch jammern auf niedrigen,
Niveau, also da da ist UK in einem ganz anderen Zustand, was die Verpeilung der der politischen Entscheidungen betrifft.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist dieser Virus ähm notiert und man spricht halt jetzt von diesen Varianten und man ist sich relativ sicher, dass da was ist. Mittlerweile hat man sich auch auf Namen geeinigt. Man spricht von dieser B eins eins sieben,
Linie und.
Na ja, also ich hatte mir, ne, muss mal kurz hier meinen Notizen ein wenig äh scrollen.
Also ich habe mir so verschiedene Bewertungen davon äh angeschaut, wie das so beurteilt wird. Und.
Klar erhöhte Transmissibilität, das scheint sich zu bestätigen, aber man sieht auch, dass jetzt diese Variante nicht per se gefährlicher ist.
Es gab Berichte, dass es sein könnte, dass äh dass es Virus mehr auf junge Leute aufspringt. Das war so eine Gefahr am Anfang.
Weil's eben in den jüngeren Bereichen höhere Infektionsraten gab, et cetera, aber.
Na ja, da gibt es einfach realistischerweise derzeit noch nicht genug Daten, um das wirklich abschließend beurteilen zu können. Grundsätzlich geht man aber davon aus, dass jetzt diese Variante keine.
Größere Gefahr bedeutet, also was jetzt die Erkrankung betrifft.
Also erhöhe, also es ist keine erhöhte Krankheitsgefahr mit dieser Variante verbunden. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Es gibt durchaus Hinweise, aber auch das ist eben nicht bestätigt, dass die Art dieser Mutation,
sehr wohl auch genau das Gegenteil bedeuten kann. Dass sehr wohl sein kann, dass man hier schon das erste Mal diese klassische Änderung sieht von der Virus will sich irgendwie verbreiten, aber er will nicht unbedingt.
Alle umbringen, weil das sind ja alles potenzielle Verbreiterhosts und,
dieser Nebeneffekt äh ist ja gar nicht gewollt. Das heißt, langfristig setzen sich halt Varianten durch, die sich gut verbreiten können und das können sie halt besser, indem sie nicht alle umbringen. Konkret.
Da bewege ich mich aber jetzt wieder komplett außerhalb meiner Expertise, so sehr ich auch versucht habe, das alles zu verstehen. Ähm diese Mutation.
Ist ja deshalb so aufgefallen, nicht nur durch diese Transmisibilität, sondern man hat sich das halt angeschaut und hat gesehen, okay, da sind jetzt relativ viele Änderungen auf einmal,
Das hat auch, glaube ich, der Drosten sehr ausführlich
im letzten Kronerbares äh Update nochmal äh besprochen. Ja, das waren dann irgendwie so so sechzehn verschiedene Motationen. Und viel wurde halt über die geredet, die dann dem Spike-Protein liegen und man wusste nicht so ganz genau, was hat das im jetzt für Auswirkung.
Ähm und.
Diese große Zahl an Mutationen, das ist jetzt nicht davon auszugehen, dass jetzt hier so ein super Virus ist und der ist jetzt einmal durch so eine immungeschwächte Person durchgegangen und dann konnte er da äh fünf Mal,
alles dreimal durchgehen ähm und dann war er so super motiert und ist da nochmal ausgetreten.
Sondern also das kann es sein, dass das so eine der Möglichkeiten eine andere Möglichkeit ist aber auch, dass es einfach ein Infektionsgeschehen ist, was aus irgendwelchen Gründen heraus für uns verborgen geblieben ist für eine längere Zeit
dass es sich zum Beispiel in einem Land entwickelt hat, wo wenig getestet wird. Und dann ist irgendeiner eingereist, ein Flugzeug, weißt du und dann,
ist das Ding auf einmal aufgefallen, du hast einfach eine Mutation, die eigentlich über mehrere Wochen, vielleicht sogar Monate gelaufen ist
überhaupt das erste Mal gesehen, ne? Oder
diese Sache mit den Nerzen, die wir schon hatten, das ist auch durchaus sein könnte, dass es eben mal einmal nochmal durch durch Tiere durchgegangen ist, sich da frei vor sich hin montiert hat, bevor es wieder auf Menschen übergesprungen ist
Also, ich sage nicht, das ist es, ja nur das sind so die Varianten, die ins Feld geführt werden, um zu erklären, warum dieses Ding so viele Mutationen hat, ohne dass man jetzt vorher Zwischenstufen beobachtet hat,
Da kommt natürlich dann auch wieder diese Sequenzierungslücke, also wir müssen ja auch erstmal sequenziert werden, um diese Änderung auch festzustellen, dass es äh sozusagen da so ein bisschen die Situation,
Am Ende müssen wir uns aber einfach auch gegen neue Varianten genauso schützen, ne?
Es gibt natürlich dieses Bedenken mit erhöhtem R, ja, also wenn's jetzt wirklich eine erhöhte Transmissibilität äh ist, wonach es eben aussieht,
dann kann es eben auch unsere ganzen Lokdownmaßnahmen, die wir bisher so als erfolgreich gefeiert haben, wenn wir überhaupt welche hatten, äh auch gleich wieder über einen Haufen werfen.
Ja weißt du irgendwie wie denn die Lokdown-Situation in London gerade ist eigentlich? Ich habe nur gehört, dass heute,
Bürgermeister und wie ein Majore Institut geklärt hat
so wegen dem Virus irgendeine keine Ahnung welche Stufe von Notstand das ist aber es ist wohl jeder dreißigste Londoner ist wohl derzeit infiziert,
siebentausend Krankenhauspatienten, tausend werden beatmet alleine in London, ja.
So und auch eben auffällig hohe Rate von neunzehn bis dreißigjährigen, die halt in Krankenhäusern.
So mit der neuen äh B eins eins sieben Variante. So.
Also wenn wenn du unzufrieden bist mit der deutschen Politik in Bezug auf Schulen, Öffnung und so äh Großbritannien hat's geschafft, die Schulen für einen Tag zu öffnen, um sie dann am nächsten Tag gleich wieder zuzumachen.
Wo man sich auch wirklich fragen kann, so was wusstet ihr am am Sonntagabend noch nicht, was ihr dann am Montagabend wusstet, so, ne? Das,
aber das ist halt so das Zeichen für dieses permanente Hin und Her von Boris Johnson und seinem Vorkommen in kompetenten Government. Das ist äh auch ein schönes Brexit-Geschenk, was sie da sich selber ins Nest gelegt haben. Ich denke, der Lokdarm wird jetzt extrem verstärkt,
trifft sie halt jetzt
gerade hart, weil wie das bei uns eben auch so war, was weiß ich, der Osten hat sich so ein bisschen in Sicherheit gewogen, ne? Vielleicht auch Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, so, ach, na ja, das ist ja alles in Bayern, ist ja alles äh in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Und genauso war's da
dass halt vor allem erstmal so Liverpool die ganzen mit England, Nordengland
Bereiche stärker betroffen waren und jetzt äh geht's halt auf einmal in Südengland äh richtig zur Sache.
Also ich glaub die sind jetzt sozusagen auf dem Weg zum superharten Lokdown, weil das kriegen Sie halt sonst irgendwie überhaupt nicht anders hin und in Irland ist es glaub ich gerade ähnlich,
Aber ich hab's jetzt nicht so genau verfolgt, als dass ich jetzt konkret benennen könnte, was da für Maßnahmen sind. Ja, also.
Die neuen Varianten sind auf jeden Fall in der Welt. Wir sollten uns, glaube ich, nicht der Illusion äh hingeben, dass sie hier nicht Fuß fassen können. Ist ja auch schon mehrfach in Deutschland dekiert worden, auch wenn's dann immer heißt, so, ja, war ja nur jemand, der eingereist ist und gleich in Quarantäne und so. Ja klar
das funktioniert bestimmt,
super, das heißt, wir werden mittelfristig wahrscheinlich auch mit dieser erhöhten Verbreitung noch unser Problem bekommen und dann kommt das sozusagen nochmal oben drauf,
Wer weiß, vielleicht ist das sozusagen auch schon ein Grund, warum wir unsere Zahlen nicht eingefangen bekommen.
Ja und äh ich mein.
Der andere Punkt ist, was Drosten ja gesagt hat, gut, dass der die neue Variante breitet sich nicht über Nacht aus, sondern Voraussetzung.
Für die Ausbreitung der einer neuen Variante ist, äh, dass es halt Infektionen gibt, so.
Ja, der Lokdown funktioniert auch sagen,
ja für die Ausbreitung der der neuen Variante erstmal, die die springt jetzt auch nicht mystisch äh so per Teleportation oder so in andere Räume. Du wird muss trotzdem noch äh jemanden,
begegnen einmal, um.
Das abzukriegen oder dich irgendwie schmiermäßig anzustecken, also ohne Kontakt verbreiten sich die neuen Varianten auch nicht, aber was wir sehen an den Zahlen ist.
Wir haben im Moment äh diese Infektion, also im Moment infiziert eine Person im Schnitt äh eine neue so.
Ähm aber in dem Moment, wo die Zahlen äh dann äh wieder steigen, wenn man auch sagen, ja, äh breiteten sich die neuen Varianten eben auch aus.
Und das dauert zwar, dass die wir in London gesehen haben, das kann so zwei, drei, vier Monate dauern, bis eine neue Variante dann zu dominierenden geworden ist, aber dann hat man den Salat halt auch.
Meinen Salat.
Genau und am schlimmsten wäre, also das Fast Case Szenario ist, dass sich halt eine Variante verbreitet, die sagen wir vielleicht erstmal erstens auf unsere Tests nicht anspricht, so.
Und.
Ja und dann eben auch so montiert, dass die Impfstoffe nicht funktionieren, sodass wir, wenn wir dann im Sommer irgendwann durch sind, wenn wir den eben von vorne anfangen können. Ja, das.
Ja okay, Spoiler zeichnet sich nicht ab. Also das ähm.
Äh
Die die Wissenschaftlergemeinde derzeit ähm noch ziemlich sicher zu sein, dass dass wir da noch lange nicht sind.
Ja, da sind wir, ne? Da sind wir noch lange nicht, deswegen, ne, ich habe Worst Case Szenario, die man kann sagen, aber bis zum Sommer ist halt noch ist eine Menge Zeit und ich erinnere mich auch noch daran, dass so.
Am Anfang gesagt wurde, ja, das Virus ist eigentlich ziemlich stabil äh so, das motiert nicht so viel und die meisten Motationen sind ja auch.
Eher negative Motationen, das ist unwahrscheinlich, dass das Virus besser wird, wenn's mutiert, was zwar alles stimmt, aber.
Das stimmt halt immer nur für eine bestimmte Zeit.
Ähm so und wenn du halt jetzt wie das der Fall ist äh weltweit halt Millioneninfizierte hast, dann äh mutiert auch dieses relativ stabile Virus. Ja, ich will jetzt nicht.
Und sagen, behaupten, das ist das, was droht und das ist auch nicht unausweichlich, aber wenn uns.
In allen Ländern jetzt die Infektion nach oben weglaufen so, dann steigt einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines solchen Szenarios.
Ja, wird das bringt uns wahrscheinlich dann äh ohnehin jetzt auch mal zum Thema Impfung und um da vielleicht sage ich mal drauf einzugehen, also.
Zunächst einmal also stimmt alles, ja? Also viel Muttation nicht gut. Und
äh heute ist es die UK-Variante oder die Südafrika-Variante. Morgen ist irgendeine andere, die vielleicht noch irgendeinen anderen Faktor mit einbringt, die nochmal Übertragungsfähiger ist oder andere unangenehme Seiteneffekte hat, die wir jetzt noch gar nicht so richtig auf dem Zettel haben
Deswegen allein schon deswegen, man kann's davon abgesehen, dass es,
täglich tausend Leute wegsterben, allein schon deswegen ist es halt geboten diesen Virus einzuschränken,
und ähm was wir auch schon erwähnt haben.
Klar, die Impfkampagne jetzt, dass es sozusagen das, was uns äh letzten Endes wieder rausholen wird aus diesem ganzen Schlamassel, da bin ich nach wie vor,
Sehr zuversichtlich, dass es das grundsätzlich tun wird
Aber wir machen es uns natürlich auch nochmal unnötig schwer, weil wir müssen eben noch länger konsequent noch mehr Leute impfen, bis wir dieses Infektionsgeschehen wirklich in den Griff kriegen,
Und auch das also auch der Impfstoff wird auch dadurch besser, dass man sozusagen weniger Institz hat.
Andererseits denke ich gibt's relativ klare Botschaften, dass man sich jetzt bei der Wirkung des Impfstoffs der Impfstoffe,
keine großen Sorgen machen muss
Das hat im Wesentlichen zwei Gründe. Zunächst einmal äh gibt's jetzt eine konkrete Studie, die das mal überprüft hat und wirklich mal Serum genommen hat von Leuten, die mit der neuen Variante
zu dem Serum genommen hat von Leuten, die mit dem Impfstoff in ähm geimpft wurden. Ja, also Serumsinne von Blut mit Antikörper
wo eben quasi jetzt nach einer bestimmten Zeit
mindestens zwei Wochen weiß ich jetzt nicht genau wie, wie lange die Leute jetzt schon geimpft waren, aber halt Leute, die diese Impfung hatten, deren Serum haben sie genommen und haben dann andererseits aktives Virus aus Proben genommen und das eben.
In Zellkulturen dann sich vermehren lassen, haben das dann eben mit diesem Blutserum von den Impfstoffen ähm in Verbindung gebracht und dann eben beobachtet.
Machen dem halt dann trotzdem den Gar aus. Und das hat auch insofern niemanden überrascht, als dass eben die Angriffsfläche,
der gebildeten Antikörper des gesamten Immunsystems, der T-Zellen der Bezellen et cetera, alles was da äh äh letzten Endes hochgefahren wird, um den Angreifer zu besiegen
Die reagieren jetzt nicht nur an diese eine kleine Stelle, wo so eine Mutation stattgefunden hat,
Und das ist einfach einen vollflächiger, eine vollflächige Reaktion, die mehr oder weniger alles abtastet, was dieses Protein halt so im Angebot hat.
Und deswegen ist jetzt eine kleine Änderung an diesem Spike Protein nicht gleich der Weltuntergang.
Ja, ja, ich ich zweifel das nicht an, äh dass jetzt sozusagen die aktuelle, also dass die die UK-Variante, äh, dass da die Impfstoffe genauso gut funktionieren, dass, ja, scheint das äh, ja, äh, nochmal.
Mehr und mehr zu bestätigen. Aber.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass du das antreibst. Ich wollte, ich wollte das nur mal festhalten, also das ist einfach die Aussage ist, man geht generell davon aus, dass ähm diese,
Immunreaktionen, die der durch die derzeitigen Impfstoffe ausgelöst wird, dass die in der Lage ist, nicht nur jetzt diese bekannt gewordenen Mutationen,
sondern mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit auch viele weitere Mutationen noch langfristig machen kann. Und grundsätzlich sind Impfstoffe sehr wirksam,
Ich meine wir haben viele Impfstoffe da draußen, die mittlerweile seit Jahrzehnten in unveränderter Form geimpft werden und auch die ganzen Mutationen von Poleo und so weiter auch immer noch,
greifen,
Also es ist einfach nichts, glaube ich, wo man sich jetzt besonders drüber ähm beunruhigen sollte. Es ist halt nur das Laufen lassen der Infektion,
fördert Varianten, die noch schwerer einzufangen sind und das bedeutet immer noch mehr Infektionen, noch mehr Leute, die krank werden, noch mehr Leute, die sterben und das ist nun mal das,
Problem.
Plus, was wir hatten, wenn sich eben bestätigt.
Dass ähm der Produktionswert ähm von der B eins eins sieben Variante tatsächlich höher ist.
Dann.
Ja, führt das auch dazu, dass die Herdenimmunität halt erst bei einem höheren Prozentsatz eintritt, das heißt, dass wir sagen noch mehr Leute impfen,
müssen äh wenn,
neue Virus unterwegs ist bevor wir ähm einen effektiven Reproduktionswert unter eins bekommen aufgrund der Erdenimmunität im.
Und da geht man raus im Moment alte Variante, sechzig Prozent, neue Variante, wenn sich das bestätigt, dass die halt.
Ja null Komma fünf bis null Komma sieben oder so auf das R oben drauf kommt,
dann reden wir halt von fünfundsiebzig bis achtzig Prozent, äh, die geimpft sein müssen oder die Krankheit durchgemacht haben müssen, bevor wir Herdenimmunität haben,
so. Und das vor dem Hintergrund, dass äh eine für mich doch.
Ja erstaunliche Zurückhaltung teilweise besteht, also bei bei bestimmten Gruppen, dass so Größenordnung zwanzig, dreißig Prozent sich nicht impfen lassen wollen.
Schauen wir mal wie die Zahl sich hält. Ja ich glaub das ist 'ne sehr volatile Umfragegröße und das mag derzeit jetzt so sein und es mag auch Leute geben die unbelehrbar sind
Aber es mag auch Leute geben, die dann einfach mit der Zeit äh meine ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir so in den nächsten Monaten,
im Wesentlichen dieselbe Botschaft zur Kenntnis nehmen werden, nämlich,
Die Leute, die geimpft wurden, werden nicht krank, die Leute, die ihr geimpft wurden, wurden nicht von der Impfung krank, die wurden nicht kurvetkrank,
und auch sonst gibt's keine größeren Probleme so. Und Leute, die nicht geimpft wurden, die sind gestorben. So. Und das setzt sich dann halt schon irgendwann auch mal fest.
Ich weiß Schwobler und so weiter, äh klar ein Problem für sich, aber das ist schon mal das Ding. An der Stelle möchte ich auch gerne nochmal ein,
Verweis machen, nämlich äh auf den von mir letzte Mal schon erwähnten Met Cram äh Kanal,
Da gibt's jetzt ein interessantes Update, nämlich genau zu dieser ganzen Frage. Okay, was wissen wir denn jetzt eigentlich über die Impfstoffe, was was haben wir bisher äh gelernt, welche Erkenntnisse gibt es denn jetzt.
Und ähm die Kernaussage des Updates ist im Wesentlichen,
Man weiß, die Impfstoffe und das bezieht sich jetzt im Wesentlichen sowohl auf die MRNA-Impfstoffe moderner, Biontech als auch äh Astra Senika, also der Großbritannien äh dieser Vektor Imstoff, der in Großbritannien vor allem genutzt wird.
Schützen, sehr effizient vor Coved neunzehn Erkrankungen, schwere Fälle gibt's keine und man weiß mittlerweile auch und das war ja auch oft die Frage,
dass sie die Infektion einschränken. Also sie verhindern nicht nur den Krankheitsausbruch, sondern sie verhindern halt auch die Infektion. Nicht zu hundert Prozent.
Aber ähm signifikant. Da war jetzt keine Zahl dran, ne. Die Debatte um allergische Reaktion.
Aber vielleicht nochmal ganz konstanz zurück, weil das ist vielleicht auch äh äh wichtig, nochmal zu bemerken.
Selbst wenn man geimpft ist äh so schließt es nicht zu hundert Prozent aus,
dass man sich infiziert und dass man auch sogar in einzelnen Fällen die Krankheit sogar weiterträgt. Das ist also nicht ausgeschlossen, sondern nur,
deutlich reduziert, so. Das ist.
Infektion weiterträgt, Krankheit trägt man nicht weiter, die Infektion.
Die Infektion. Ja gut äh Infektion ist eigentlich die äh Krankheit, aber ja ähm gut.
Weitertragen tut man den Virus, ob dann die andere Person davon krank wird, steht ja nochmal auf einem anderen Blatt, deswegen mache ich da gerne diesen Unterschied. Aber der Impfstoff schützt die meisten Leute davor, überhaupt krank zu werden.
Die krank werden, werden nicht schwer krank. Das ist sozusagen.
Das ist der der Haupthauptpunkt mein Punkt war nur sagen vor dem Hintergrund ah ja ähm,
so jetzt Impfung ist dann sozusagen der komplette Freibrief nichts anderes mehr machen zu müssen und sich dann nicht mehr fernhalten zu müssen, dass sie sich von
älteren Menschen oder so, die noch nicht geimpft worden sind. Ja.
Genau, man man ist, man ist nicht raus aus dem Spiel, äh es schränkt es wahrscheinlich ein, also dass man eben so sehr sich infiziert
noch mit dem Virus, sodass man in der Lage ist, diesen auch weiter zu tragen, also dass er sich schnell genug im Rachen repliziert und weitergetragen werden kann
bevor die eigentliche eigene Antikörperarmee
zuschlägt, auch das wird geringer und das mag auch sehr viel mit der Zeit zu tun haben, wie lange diese ähm.
Wie lange jetzt diese Impfung zurückliegt, weil es dauert einfach ein paar Wochen, bis der Körper das richtig hochfahren kann und später, wenn die unmittelbare Reaktion abgeschwellt ist
stellt das Immunsystem ja um und muss sich dann quasi erinnern, aber dann ist eben das Erinnerungspotential noch sehr stark. Es kann also noch sein, dass man Leute infiziert.
Und deswegen möchten wir eben.
Müssen wir eben sehr viele Leute impfen, dass einfach, dass das Virus einfach nicht mehr genug Host findet, um um sich selber zu Supersprayden.
Ja. Ja, wie sehen denn äh wo wir bei Impfungen sind, wie sehen denn die Zahlen aus, wie kommen wir denn voran? Mit.
Lass mich nochmal ganz kurz noch die Erkenntnis
von diesem von diesem Update äh bringen, weil ich fand das äh äh sehr schön, weil sie alles so aufgegriffen haben, was eben auch gerade so debattiert wird und da gehören ja auch diese allergischen Reaktionen dazu
ne? Und da meinten sie so, ja, das ist natürlich etwas, worauf sich die Medien stürzen, ne? Da hast du jetzt irgendwie eine Person.
Die äh stark allergisch reagiert dadrauf. Das sind aber dann eben in der in der Regel Leute, die ohnehin auf Sachen allergisch reagieren
Also wo das Immunsystem so eine Schwäche hat, dass es Dinge, die dem Körper nicht schaden als schädlich ansehen. Und da ist dann quasi der Impfstoff.
Auch sowas. Weil der Impfstoff ja letzten,
diese Virusproteine macht, das heißt erstens ist es sozusagen durchaus vorstellbar, dass diese Leute diese Reaktion auch haben, wenn sie sich mit dem Virus infizieren, weil da ist der Infostoff jetzt auch nichts anderes, ja? Das heißt,
Das Impfen macht dann auch nichts anderes, du hitzt diese Reaktion wahrscheinlich sowieso. Andererseits ist sie halt sehr, sehr, sehr selten. Und die Leute, die davon wirklich betroffen sind, die wissen das auch schon vorher, dass sie dieses Problem haben.
Ja, wenn sie nicht rein zufällig genau in dem Moment das erste Mal in ihrem Leben merken, dass sie irgendwie allergisch überregieren. Ist dann aber auch etwas, was dann bei der Impfung relativ schnell auftritt und dann auch
behandelt werden kann. Bisher ist da noch keiner von gestorben. Die Leute mussten dann halt äh im Krankenhaus behandelt werden
wenn Leute die starke Allergiker äh sind oder so eine Immunschwäche haben, geimpft werden und das vorher angeben, dann wissen auch schon alle Bescheid so okay,
beobachten wir jetzt mal nicht fünfzehn Minuten, sondern du wirst sowieso mal gleich im Krankenhaus geimpft,
und gar nicht erst hier im Impfzentrum, ja? Weil da kannst du dann irgendwie einen Tag beobachtet werden und wenn da was dann passiert, dann gibt's auch alle Mittel im medizinischen äh Baukasten, um dir zu helfen und dann,
kriegen wir das irgendwie auch schon in Griff. Das ist sozusagen äh gut, ne? Und interessantes,
ähm interessanter Vergleich, der dann aufkam war, dass also im Prinzip Erdnüsse ein größeres Problem darstellen.
Also du hast sozusagen durch das Verteilen von Erdnüssen, schaffst du hier mehr Gefährdung als durch das Verteilen dieses Impfstoffs,
jetzt einfach jedem eine Erdnuss in die Hand drückst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da eine allergische Reaktion hochgetreten wird, noch ein bisschen größer.
Ja, ähm man weiß ja auch, dass.
Was sozusagen der Auslöser ist. Also der Impfstoff besteht ja im Wesentlichen nur eigentlich aus dieser diesem kurzen RNA-Strang, also dem,
leicht modifizierten Teil des Originalvirus, also der Teil im Virus, der eben dieses Bike-Protein kodiert, leicht modifiziert, kommt in so ein,
Lipidmantel, das sind also so Fettsäuren, die das alles umgeben. Das müssen sie tun.
Damit diese RNA überhaupt in den Körper transportiert werden kann und in äh eine Zelle geraten kann. Während dieses
dieser Stoff nicht drumherum würde diese RNA einfach zerfallen beziehungsweise beim Eintritt in den Körper, wenn du nur RNA spritzen würdest, dann würde das einfach vom Immunsystem so schnell weggeräumt werden, da würde gar nicht erst groß gefragt werden,
Deswegen ist eben quasi so ein temporärer Schutz nötig und dafür gibt es eben diesen diese Lipidhülle.
Wie die designed ist, das ist die eigentliche Magie dieser Impfstoffe. Also natürlich ist die,
Kernmagie tatsächlich in dieser RNA, aber da weiß man jetzt sozusagen, was man da reinschreiben muss. Das das die Kette ist bekannt, die kann man sich von der Webseite abtippen in seinen RNA Brinter äh äh eingeben und dann und dann hat man das.
Kunst des Impfstoffes liegt in der Hülle und da sieht man ja auch schon den Unterschied zwischen dem Impfstoff, den Biontech gemacht hat,
eine extreme Kühlung braucht, um nicht zu zerfallen. Ne, diese minus siebzig,
Grad die quasi erforderlich sind, um das Ding ein halbes Jahr auch halten zu können und wenn's dann ausgepackt ist, muss nach fünf Tagen verimpft werden.
Der Moderne Impfstoff hat halt eine leicht anders designte äh Fetthülle, die eben nicht ganz so.
Anfällig ist und diese Hülle, das ist auch das, was letzten Endes diese allergischen Reaktionen auslöst und ähm das kam so in dem Gespräch raus,
die sind jetzt auch nicht mit ihrem Latein am Ende
bei Bier und Tich und bei moderner, sondern die beobachten das, die schauen sich das an, die machen sich Gedanken dadrüber, wie sieht das noch besser designen können
dass es eben auch sehr gut sein kann, dass so in den in den Entwicklungen dieser äh Impfstoffe in der nächsten Zeit diese allergischen Reaktionen so noch weiter reduziert werden können.
Und es ist auch, was mir auffällt, es ist gut, dass es äh wenn man nur der Lipidmantel ist und zwar aus dem Grund, weil,
damit die Menge des Allergens halt,
begrenzt ist auf tatsächlich den Impfstoff. Viel schlimmer wär's, wenn jetzt der Auslöser äh irgendeins der Proteine wäre, die die Zellen dann selber,
herstellen, ja? Weil dann könnt's nämlich äh äh wirklich gefährlich
werden, äh, wenn der Körper sagt anfängt Sachen zu produzieren, dann kommt halt potentiell zu sowas wie so ein Zitukinstürmen und so, das ist halt wäre halt super gefährlich, aber wenn's halt einfach nur
der Mantel ist dann ja.
Mal denken, auch bei den relativ kleinen Mengen äh so, äh dass das wahrscheinlich in keinem Fall lebensbedrohlich äh äh sein dürfte.
Ja, das ist ja auch überhaupt dieses Wunder, ne? Also wir haben einen einen Impfstoff, der sozusagen komplett ohne Proteinmaterial äh auskommt, sondern alles, was wir kriegen, ist so ein so ein Stück Code,
der halt einfach unseren Zellen sagt, was zu produzieren ist, dann wird das irgendwie produziert, dann kommt sofort das Antikörpersystem, das Immunsystem und sagt so, ja, was ist denn das hier? Da bauen wir aber mal jetzt einen Sound rum und das ist im Prinzip schon die ganze Geschichte.
Ja, dann haben sie sich noch zum Ende äh der Frage gewidmet, ob denn saß zwei äh überhaupt beseitigt werden kann.
Da waren sie eigentlich nicht ganz pessimistisch, sage ich mal, so, ja, sondern es war so, na ja, also und in der aktuellen Situation,
ist es nicht so ohne Weiteres zu verdrängen. Also bevor nicht diese Impfkampagnen jetzt wirklich nennenswerten Umfang entwickelt haben, ist klar, dass äh da da lässt sich jetzt derzeit einfach zu wenig machen. Der Zug ist abgesegelt. Aber,
In ein paar Jahren kann das dann schon wieder anders sein. Ist nicht unbedingt wahrscheinlich, aber ist auch nicht komplett,
unwahrscheinlich. Sie halten es also durchaus für möglich. Man muss auch sagen, auch wenn die ganze Situation scheiße ist, wir haben im Prinzip noch extrem,
Glück gehabt, denn das Virus mag zwar eine schwere Krankheit auslösen,
Aber es ist eigentlich ähm in zwei Hinsichten relativ harmlos. Es ist nämlich nicht ansatzweise so übertragbar wie Masern.
Ja, Masern, da das hat einfach eine.
Einem R null von zehn und so äh.
Genau, also da geht's so richtig zur Sache. Also das wäre zum Beispiel schon mal ein echtes Problem gewesen, da hätte wahrscheinlich, dass China noch nicht mal irgendwie Content bekommen.
Ähm und andererseits ist es aber auch nicht so tödlich, wie jetzt März war. Merz war ziemlich äh gefährlich oder auch.
Saß eins auch äh mhm.
Haben sie sich glaube, dass viele in dem Moment nicht, sie sprachen von Mers oder
Ebola und ähm auch das sehen wir halt nicht, sondern es gibt halt dann noch, ne? Es gibt natürlich schwere Verläufe, viele Leute sterben, ja, aber kein Vergleich zu dem, was eben diese Vorgängerviren ausgelöst haben.
Ja
Ist halt nur deshalb überhaupt ein Problem, weil sich eben dieses Virus, diese Präsytomatische Phase ausgedacht hat, so dieses ich verteil mich einfach schon mal bevor ich irgendwelche Krankheitssymptome mache. Das ist eigentlich der Erfolgsfaktor
dass es mehr ist nicht gelungen und so, bei Saß eins, da ging's halt mit der Infektion auch erst los, als die Leute schon krank wurden und deswegen konnte es dann auch eingedämmt werden, weil quasi die Leute in dem Moment automatisch gewarnt wurden, so hier, du
könntest unter Umständen infektiös sein. Und jetzt gibt's halt ein paar Tage Vorlauf und die paar Tage Vorlauf machen äh.
Machen im Prinzip alles so schwierig.
Also saß eins, hat sie eine Litalitätsrate so zwischen zehn und dreißig Prozent der Leute sind gestorben.
Aber,
ist es halt auch ausgerottet. Es kommt nicht mehr vor insofern sicher Plus äh Gewissenheit von der ganzen Menge auch Grippe äh äh Viren stemmen, die irgendwann einfach ausgestorben,
sind. So insofern ja denke ich auch äh gibt's gute Gründe anzunehmen, dass äh wir.
Hinbekommen.
Gut, dann sollten wir vielleicht mal noch um einen Blick werfen auf die Impfkampagne, wie es da so läuft
Also ich habe so in der Woche eine Menge Feedback,
kommen aus zahlreichen Kanälen, vielen Dank dafür, es war fast schon ein bisschen unübersichtlich, gab auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so einen einzelnen Tenor, ich weiß nicht, was bei dir alles so aufgelaufen ist, aber ich habe relativ viele,
subjektive Eindrücke aus Impfzentren bekommen von
Ärzten, die da arbeiten von Leuten, die dort in irgendeiner Form anders tätig sind, mithelfen, sich freiwillig gemeldet haben selber Impfstoffe auch spritzen oder sonst irgendwie äh hilfreich tätig sind.
Und das äh aus verschiedenen Quellen relativ viel aus Stuttgart interessanterweise.
Was jetzt grade gar nicht alles war, äh, war es ein bisschen viel auf einmal für mich in dem Moment. Grundsätzlich kann man sagen.
Läuft an, aber nicht schnell.
Und die Gründe dafür sind vielfältig. Ich meine jetzt in der öffentlichen Debatte ist halt gleich wieder so, wir haben nicht genug Impfstoff und so bestellt.
Hätten wir jetzt den ganzen Impfstoff bekommen, den wir bestellt hätten.
Ja, dann dann hätte es auch vollkommen ausgereicht. Das Problem ist nur, die Produktion läuft halt langsam an. Es gibt Verteilungsprobleme, es gibt logistische Probleme.
Aber ich glaube die, dass die Zahlen an sich noch so niedrig sind.
Ist so eine so eine so eine Mischung aus verschiedenen Faktoren, wo man jetzt gar nicht genau sagen kann, das ist jetzt hier der einzelne Grund, sondern hier ich habe so den Eindruck, es müssen sich mehrere Dinge verbessern, bevor es wirklich insgesamt besser war,
Das fängt an bei Terminbuchungen. Also erstmal haben wir natürlich wieder bei Deutschland, ja, jedes Land macht's einem anders.
Im Süden hast du irgendwie vier Länder, die sich in einem Anmeldeportal zusammengefunden haben. Ich glaube, so Hessen, Baden-Württemberg und so weiter, ne, da die haben alle dasselbe Portal und das erste, was man machen muss auf der Webseite ist erstmal,
ähm dein Bundesland auswählen, wo aber dann eben nicht sechzehn Bundesländer sind, sondern eben vier,
andere machen's also anders. In Berlin gibt's überhaupt gar keinen Möglichkeit, sich Termine zu holen, sondern hier sollen die Leute erstmal angeschrieben werden. Was auch durchaus verstehen kann, aber,
Tatsache ist, es gibt wieder sehr unterschiedliche Systeme und Herangehensweisen und Lösungen, wie das alles gemacht werden soll. Was natürlich das Problem hat,
dass wir jetzt hier im Podcast nicht sagen können,
geht zu dieser Telefonnummer, geht zu dieser Webseite oder äh setzt euch einfach nur still äh aufs Sofa und wartet und äh äh leert euren Briefkasten, weil unklar
einfach kann man nicht sagen, was jetzt eigentlich wirklich die Regel ist. Es ist äh eine Vielzahl. Dann.
Dem Moment, wo man dann ausgewählt ist.
Sich einen Termin äh holt, funktioniert das wohl auch teilweise mit den Terminen nicht, ne? Gut, Software muss geschrieben werden, muss funktionieren, muss bedient werden, muss in die richtigen Kanäle läufen. Und dann äh hast du natürlich auch noch das Problem,
nicht unbedingt alle Uhrzeiten auch für alle geeignet sind. Also in Stuttgart ist es so, dass wohl im Zentrum von sieben Uhr bis einundzwanzig Uhr offen hat,
dann ist vormittags relativ wenig los und am Nachmittag wollen dann auf einmal ganz viele und am Abend Apps dann halt ab zwanzig Uhr auch wieder ab.
Das ist jetzt wie gesagt nur anekdotische Information.
Das mag sich jetzt auch schon wieder an anderen Stellen anders darstellen, beziehungsweise auch anders entwickelt haben. Ja, dann müssen wir mal gucken äh wie's dabei äh wie es da so weitergeht,
Was aber ganz interessant war, ähm es gab ja jetzt auch eine offizielle.
Erlaubnis der EMA diesen Impffläschchen nicht nur die bisher vorgeschriebenen fünf, sondern auch ganz offiziell auch sechs Dosierungen zu entnehmen,
Fragt man sich halt so.
Okay, wenn da eigentlich nur fünf drin sein sollen, wieso sind da sechs drin oder vielleicht auch manchmal sieben? Das hat sowas mit den Produktionstoleranzen zu tun, ne? Maschinen füllen das ab.
Haben natürlich irgendwie äh auch so ihre Ungenauigkeiten und um sicherzustellen, dass auf jeden Fall fünf Dosierungen immer drin sind
Machen sie halt so und so viel Prozent mehr rein
und rein technisch, wenn du quasi in der Lage bist, die vollständige Menge äh ohne Verluste zu entnehmen, kannst du dann eben,
immer sechs daraus holen und in manchen Fällen auch mal sieben.
Und jetzt sind halt sechs zugelassen worden und das ging ja relativ schnell und ich habe aber jetzt eigentlich aus mehreren Kanälen gehört, dass sie das halt einfach schon trotzdem die ganze Zeit gemacht haben.
Also sechs äh aus der Flasche rausholen, was nicht schlecht ist, weil das bedeutet im Prinzip zwanzig Prozent mehr Impfstoff, was jetzt keine schlechte Zahl ist.
Ja, dann äh wird es sich natürlich dadurch jetzt auch verbessern. Wir haben jetzt auch noch den moderner Impfstoff, der jetzt zugelassen wurde diese Woche.
Das ist zwar jetzt auch nicht gerade unbedingt eine Flutung, aber auch hier die Kapazität liegt bei fünfzig Millionen Dosen, allein für Deutschland. Die ganze EU nimmt, glaube ich, erstmal hundertsechzig Millionen Dosierungen ab.
Das heißt auch der moderne Impfstoff wird dazukommen in der nächsten Zeit so, bin gespannt, was wie das so äh läuft. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ein Impfzentrum sich sicherlich auf einen Impfstoff festlegen wird,
und nicht mehrere verschiedene Prozedere, die miteinander vielleicht inkompatibel sind. Gleichzeitig fährt,
bedeutet meiner Meinung nach wohl, dass wir eher,
Impfzentren, die jetzt eröffnen, regionale Impfzentren, insbesondere, also die auch so nicht ganz so in den Ballungsräumen sind
die vielleicht dann auf dem moderner Impfstoff gehen, weil der dann eben auch nicht diese hohen Kühlungsanforderungen haben, ne? Eben nicht diese Minus siebzig Grad,
gebrauchen, dass äh ja, das wird dann sicherlich demnächst auch Einzug halten. Ja.
Das ist eigentlich so das, was ich so mitgenommen habe jetzt in dieser äh Woche und ich kann nur hoffen,
dass dass wir's irgendwie auf die Kette kriegen und wirklich diese ganze Impfkampagne hochgefahren bekommen.
Ja ich hab mir grad mal die aktuellen Zahlen vom Impfquotenmonitoring des RKI geholt so bis siebte erste da ist um das halt auch.
Aufgeschlüsselt so nach Bundesländern kommunativ und äh sagen Differenz zum Vortag und Impf.
Pro tausend Einwohner,
jetzt also auch wieder die Situation, dass man wahrscheinlich jetzt diese Daten täglich archivieren muss, weil es keine Zeitreihen gibt, sondern sie immer nur die Impfungen kommunativ und die Differenz zum Vortag äh äh berichten.
Okay, dann mal los, Pavel.
Ähm.
Also insgesamt äh deutschland äh weit erstmal äh sind jetzt vierhundertsechsundsiebzigtausendneunhundertneunundfünfzig, also nicht ganz eine halbe Million Leute wurden äh nein, wurden,
Impfungen wurden durchgeführt, so Impfungen.
Was wahrscheinlich fast alles äh auch erste Dosen gewesen sein könnten und.
So
Weil es kann, es kann einfach noch keine zweite Dose ausgegeben worden sein.
Und äh sagen Differenz zum Vortag waren halt fünfzigtausend, das heißt irgendwie deutschlandweit fünfzigtausend äh Leute pro Tag.
Und.
Am weitesten ist Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, was so pro tausend Einwohner angeht, die sind nämlich,
Ja, als doppelt so weit wie alle anderen sind bei fünfzehn pro Tausend, was aber auch alles äh ja, das ist nichts, das ist sagen nichts und,
am langsamsten, ja, scheint was Niedersachsen, die Thüringen.
Thüringen und Sachsen, also Thüringen drei Komma sieben, Sachsen drei Komma acht und Niedersachsen vier Komma null äh.
Impfungen pro hunderttausend Einwohner und.
Berlin liegt mit sieben Komma zwei sogar relativ weit vorne.
Pro hunderttausend, ja.
Äh pro tausend. Protausend.
Tausend Einwohner. Also pro Promille. Mhm.
Also Berlin dann mit quasi null Komma sieben Prozent äh im Moment oder sieben Komma zwei Promille und Israel lag.
Hast du lass mal kurz bei Deutschland noch bleiben, hast du äh das ist schon Leute, die geipft wurden.
Ja, ich kenne somit eine Person.
Selber nicht persönlich gesprochen, weiß aber das äh aber das ist auch Frontline Worker, jemand der sozusagen richtig,
im Intubationsbereich unterwegs ist, also die Leute erreicht es dann schon, ne? Ach ja genau das an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal, wir hatten ja diese ganze Debatte mit den.
Im Verweigerern, ne? So im im Pflegebereich. Da kam auch relativ viel Feedback, ne? Und ähm mit einerseits mit verschiedenen Erklärungsmustern,
was denn sozusagen jetzt der Grund dafür sein kann, ob berechtigt oder nicht berechtigt, was sie aber auch,
Stark habe durchscheiden lassen, ist, dass es hier doch einen erheblichen Unterschied gibt zwischen Pflegebereich.
Und Klinikbereich. Also viele haben sich gemeldet mit ja also bei uns im Krankenhaus.
Kenne ich niemanden, der irgendwie nicht sofort äh Jahr schreit, wenn äh noch eine Impfdosis irgendwo zu vergeben ist. Ja, also da sieht's halt
ganz anders aus. Und es ist natürlich auch irgendwo erklärbar, äh was natürlich im Klinikbereich ist auch einfach mit einer ganz anderen
medizinischen Kompetenzen damit natürlich einer ganz anderen Nähe zu dem Thema zu tun
wenn ich durch eigenes Wissen dann eben durch das Wissen oder die Einschätzung von Kollegen ich denke mal, dass es dann halt eben auch etwas, was sich dann über die Zeit auch in die anderen Bereiche mit reinmacht, auch wenn ich's grundsätzlich für schwierig halte.
Unternehmen zu erlauben, Altenheime zum Beispiel oder Pflegeheime zu betreiben.
Wo es irgendwie ein Personal gibt, was was sich nicht impfen lässt. Also es ist einfach das gibt mein Kop.
Nee, geht nicht, aber aber es ist halt so, was man halt so ist, gerade in der, in der alten äh Pflege, äh aber.
Nicht nur dort, aber vor allem äh da arbeiten natürlich ganz, ganz viele Hilfskräfte, die null medizinische Ausbildung haben,
äh die sich also deswegen auch gar nicht von der Gesamtbevölkerung unbedingt erstmal unterscheiden dürften.
Was so Impfbereitschaft angeht, aber nachvollziehbar ist es trotzdem nicht irgendwie, wenn ich hier.
Weiß, dass ich mit alten Menschen arbeite, die mit einer ziemlich hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit sterben, wenn ich sie anstecke. Also ja.
Aber da ist offensichtlich auch, ich weiß nicht, esoterik und Misstrauen und so und ja Donald Trump hat sich ja auch als noch vor seiner Präsidentschaft als äh im Wahlkampf, als Impfskeptiker geortet, Memoring.
Jetzt hat er sich wahrscheinlich sofort impfen lassen.
Unbekannt, aber äh na ja gut, der hat's ja schon durchgemacht insofern, aber trotzdem glaube ich.
Ist es wahrscheinlich trotzdem gefahren. Weiß ich aber nicht genau. Ja okay, dann können wir ja mal den internationalen Vergleich machen, der ist glaube ich erforderlich.
Ja, stimmt, den haben wir vorhin ja nicht in den kompletten äh Zahlenblock gemacht. Wir sind ein bisschen äh gehüpft.
Ja, ich wollte kurz bei Deutschland bleiben, aber äh schauen wir mal, also weltweit sind bisher angeblich siebzehn Komma sechs fünf Millionen äh Impfungen ausgeteilt worden
Großteil davon äh in den USA, da läuft's relativ streat an. China ist auch ganz gut unterwegs.
Was die absoluten Zahlen betrifft, dann kommen schon Israel und Israel ist halt nach wie vor der absolute Spitzenreiter
was so den die Impfung pro Bevölkerungsanteil betrifft, da sind sie nämlich jetzt bei fast zwanzig Prozent, also.
Stand gestern neunzehn Komma fünf fünf Prozent. Das ist ähm das ist eine gute Zahl und man kann sich natürlich fragen.
Was erlaube Israel, was was machen die da eigentlich besser als äh wir? Ich glaube, das ist für uns ein bisschen schwierig zu beurteilen, aber es mag so eine Mischung sein aus einem.
Ohnehin krisengeprobten Land, was in der Lage ist und äh oft und immer wieder gelernt hat, äh
Momenten der Krise sich schnell gut äh zu organisieren, um überhaupt überlebensfähig zu sein. Das mag jetzt hier eine Hilfe sein. Dann werden sie sicherlich Glück gehabt haben, dass sie auf den richtigen Impfstoff gesetzt haben und da die entsprechenden Bestellmengen,
frühzeitig angemeldet haben.
Schwer zu beantworten. Dahinter liegt also Vereinigte Arabische Emirate, das ist ja auch ein relativ überschaubarer, aber auch finanziell sehr gut ausgestatteter Bereich äh der Welt. Ähnlich sieht's auch aus in Barain.
Das überrascht mich jetzt nicht so sehr, dass äh die da so gut abschneiden. Mich überrascht es nur, dass es nur die beiden sind in diesem ganzen Ölreichtumsgebiet, also von Saudi-Arabien.
Die haben jetzt gerade so ein bisschen angefangen. Ja, weiß nicht. Dann UK hat natürlich Zeitvorsprung, äh USA ein bisschen auch,
dann kommt aber auch schon Dänemark und Island ist auch gut unterwegs mit äh eins Komma vier Prozent.
Mhm. Ja und dann sind wir aber schon äh glaube ich unter ein Prozent allen anderen.
Slowenien, Italien, Kanada, Estland, Spanien und dann Deutschland.
So viel zu äh Import im Import und Impfweltmeister werden wir auf jeden Fall nicht mehr. Das äh glaube ich, können wir uns abschminken.
Ja gut, man muss aber auch natürlich zu dem zu der ganzen äh Sache sagen, eigentlich.
Konnte man jetzt nicht erwarten, dass es äh schon in zweitausendzwanzig überhaupt mit dem Impfen losgeht irgendwo, das ist also schon eher eine positive Überraschung.
Aber dass das natürlich dauert so das war auch absehbar aber,
Just das jetzt so lange voraussichtlich dauern wird,
so das war vermutlich vermeidbar, also jetzt bei uns Israel wird wohl voraussichtlich sie rechnen damit,
irgendwann im März durch zu sein mit dem Impfen, dann so sagen, dass sie irgendwann im März quasi Herdenimunität erreicht haben.
Äh ja äh da bin ich äh gerade ein bisschen neidisch und ähm so ja da das hätte besser laufen können. Ich meine, es ist.
Okay, wahrscheinlich werden wir bis zum Sommer trotzdem noch durch sein, aber auch allein die Tatsache, dass man jetzt nochmal nachgelegt hat und dass dieses neue Werk auch erst im März, glaube ich, aufmacht oder im Februar
was jetzt da in Deutschland eröffnet wird, so da fragt man sich halt schon so hm.
Ja also gut, also gucke mal, dieses also das Werk, von dem du redest, ist ein ist ein Werk, was was Bio-Tech,
quasi übernommen hat.
Ist äh seit Jahren schon ein Chemiestandort, äh so ein, so ein Pharmastandort, das überhaupt nichts Neues in Marburg und die haben halt komplett das ganze Werk und die ganze Belegschaft übernommen. Das haben sie aber schon im September getan.
Also Monate, bevor es irgendeine Zulassung äh gab. Und du kannst halt nicht mal eben so ein Werk.
Von einem Tag auf den anderen äh hm das ist.
Also das hat was mit Geräten, Maschinen, Prozessen, Protestungen, Personal, Schulungen, Prozessen.
IT-Infrastruk.
Ja also das ist ich fände es schon bemerkenswert wenn sie sozusagen das innerhalb dieser Zeit hinbekommen. So die sind da dran und dann wollen sie halt auch zweihundertfünfzig Millionen
Dosen in in einem halben oder im Quartals war es jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr. Also auf jeden Fall eine relativ hohe Menge an äh ich glaube sechzig Millionen pro Monat oder so was war's. Äh produzieren,
Wir werden im Laufe dieses Jahres sogar im Land die Produktionsmengen haben und wir werden auch genug.
Also ich glaube, dass die Verfügbarkeit des Impfschoffs ist am Ende nicht das Problem, sondern es hängt eigentlich jetzt alles an der Logistik ab.
Wenn der Impfstoff da ist.
Dann ist es nur eine Frage des wie schnell kriegen wir das jetzt irgendwie in die Leute rein? Und das sind durchaus diverse skalierende Faktoren dabei.
Du kannst mehr Impfzentren aufsetzen, geht.
Wenn du Personal kriegst und so klar und natürlich auch das Funding dafür, aber man kann das hochfahren,
Von daher würde ich jetzt noch nicht sagen, dass äh aller Hoffnungen äh fahren gelassen werden muss, sondern es gibt schon noch eine Möglichkeit, bis zum Sommer das eigentliche Ziel zu erreichen.
Ja? Also in Berlin äh jetzt waren's halt gestern zweitausendzweihundertsiebenundvierzig Impfungen, die insgesamt.
Durchgeführt wurden.
Und ähm ja eigentlich äh sind die Impfzentren jetzt schon eher auf das zehnfache ausgelegt.
Also ein großes Impfzentrum in Berlin kann theoretisch fünftausend Impfungen pro Tag
machen, zumindest dafür sind sie geplant, ob sie es real auch schaffen würden, wenn alle anderen Faktoren äh ideal laufen, weiß ich nicht, aber da ist schon noch eine ganze Menge Luft nach oben
mag aber eben auch noch einfach was mit der Verfügbarkeit der Impfstoffe zu tun haben.
Ja? Äh auch mit so logistischen Schwierigkeiten, da gibt's ja gerade so eine Debatte mit ähm müssen jetzt sozusagen, wenn die, wenn jetzt hier Person A geimpft wird,
nochmal geimpft werden. Setze ich jetzt dadrauf, dass der Flow von neuem Impfstoffmaterial.
So kontinuierlich ist, so Just and Time mäßig das in drei Wochen aber auch wirklich diese Dosis vorliegt oder.
Ja? Oder muss ich quasi jetzt eine Zweitdosis erstmal beiseite legen, damit die auch auf jeden Fall da ist.
Das ist so die Frage, geht man in so ein Vorratshaltung oder in so ein Justin Time Production Modus.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Faktor, der erstmal ausgekugelt werden muss.
Ja euch, ich denke mal wahrscheinlich genau der, der das,
Optimum liegt irgendwo in der Mitte, dass man auf der einen Seite bisschen Reserve aufbaut für,
Schwankungen äh wie groß genug ist und aber nicht irgendwie ein kompletten äh drei Wochen Puffer oder so äh jetzt rumliegen hat, das.
Genau, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt Chef von so einem Ins Impfzentrum wärst, ja, dann würdest du auch sagen, hm okay.
Mhm. Ja.
Das muss ich jetzt irgendwie abwägen, ja, weil ich will h
auf gar keinen Fall, dass dann dieser zweite Termin vergeigt wird. Ja, auf der anderen Seite möchte ich möglichst viele Leute überhaupt erstmal auf ersten Termin schicken, weil jeden, den du jetzt sozusagen noch eine Impfdosis mehr,
gibst als Erster, umso höher ist dann wiederum auch der Bedarf für die zweite, ne.
Ja, aber äh in dem Moment, wenn sich dann rausstellt, okay, es kommen jeden Tag äh zunehmende Lieferungen äh äh hier an, ja.
Dann wird sich das auch auch ändern, ne? Aber jetzt habe ich gerade eher so das das dieses Foto von diesem großen Lastwagen, der äh war, wo dann so eine halbe Palette mit drei Kisten Impfstoff drauf la,
wo er sich auch fragt, warum er das jetzt nicht mit einem Sprinter äh durch die Gegend gefahren habt, ne.
Ja, gut, ich denke, jetzt haben wir eigentlich unser ähm Pulver schon verschossen für diese Woche. Das wird mal eine etwas knappere Sendung, aber muss ja auch mal sein.
Ja, wir sind haben wir, glaube ich, trotzdem irgendwie eine ganze äh Menge durch. Haben wir sonst noch irgendwelche ähm.
Auffälligen Artikel, was ist, was es mit dem äh Eirosolen in Hochhäusern, die durch die Rohre klettern.
Ja, die Notiz.
Horrorstory.
Okay, ich kann das ja mal aufgraben. Ich habe das schon ein bisschen länger äh äh rumliegen, weil ich das jetzt auch nicht so mega hinterher recherchiert habe, aber das ist so eine, das ist schon eine etwas ältere äh Sache. Ich weiß grad nicht ganz genau, von wann
Paper ist, ich schaue mal kurz, das ist aus,
September. Das sind also schon relativ äh alte.
Sachen, aber das kommt aus Asien und dann haben sie nämlich mal geschaut,
habe mir jetzt leider keine detaillierten äh Notizen gemacht, wie das jetzt genau alles raus war, aber
Die Kernaussage war die, sie haben halt festgestellt, dass äh Ariosolausbreitung auch so über die ganzen scheiße Kanäle äh von Hochhäusern geraten ist.
Und ähm da gab's also so Fälle, dass so Familien über drei,
übereinander liegenden Wohnungen wohnten in so einem Haus
das aber dann eben durch die Virus der sozusagen ausgeschissen wurde in diese Black Water äh,
Kanalisation dann eben durch so Rückstau und schlechte Ventilation, dass dann eben teilweise über die anderen Ausflüsse wieder so rein.
Äh äh blubbert ist. Also es kam dann so quasi so aus der,
Badewanne, die Gase raus und haben damit dann sozusagen diese Wohnung äh benebelt und dann gab's dann eben eine Infektionsübertragung über Wohnungsgrenzen hinweg.
Also auch so ne Sachen können äh passieren, ne.
Da ich hatte mir das, glaube ich, mal vor allem deshalb notiert, als wir noch diese ganze Debatte mit irgendwie Agrosole äh und welche Bedeutung haben sie denn jetzt eigentlich, ne? Das ist äh,
dokumentiert. Also das eine war jetzt in Korea.
Wo so Hochhaussituationen äh untersucht wurde und das andere was ich jetzt gerade gar nicht wo das war.
Ich verlinke das auf jeden Fall in Shonots, könnt ihr euch ja angucken, falls ihr noch ein bisschen Lust auf Horrorszenarien habt.
Hast du schon wieder mein mein positiven Ausblick äh torpediert am Ende?
Sorry äh äh ja äh ja ich.
Wie machst du das immer? Doomsteepabe.
Weiß es nicht, ich weiß es nicht. Äh aber ja ich meine gut ähm ja Situation hoffnungslos, aber nicht ernst. Äh äh.
Ja, ich hätte mir auch so einen schönen Satz irgendwie notiert, mit der man diese Zeit vielleicht zusammenfassen kann, so. Trotz halbherziger Maßnahmen, uneinheitlichen Regelungen und zahlreichen Ausnahmen und unverständlichen Teils widersprüchlichen Anordnungen
konnte das Infektionsgeschehen noch nicht zurückgedrängt werden.
Unsere Hoffnungen liegen nun auf einer Variante des Vios, die sich noch schneller in die Bevölkerung einfressen kann als die Alte.
Ja, so sieht's gerade aus, ne?
Gut Leute, lasst euch nicht äh klein kriegen, bleibt äh gesund und zu Hause und so weiter, sobald ihr äh äh könnt und geht einfach erstmal weiterhin noch so ein bisschen vom Schlimmsten aus, dann wird's nämlich nicht so schlimm werden.
Das wäre so mein Tipp und wir gucken einfach mal, wie sich das so entwickelt. Ich denke mal, wir werden in den nächsten Woche.
Nochmal,
klareres Gefühl dafür bekommen, was denn jetzt eigentlich diese Weihnachtszeit äh mit sich gebracht hat und vielleicht dann eben auch eine etwas bessere Einschätzung
Wie man denn nun mit der ganzen Schulsituation und beziehungsweise überhaupt mit der Logdown Situation an sich umgehen sollte.
Ja und wahrscheinlich werden wir aber so oder so, äh wenn wir Ermüdungserscheinungen.
Sehen,
Also äh das ist mir auch das, sagen normalerweise Maßnahmen, neue Maßnahmen so nach zwei, drei Wochen,
den Höhepunkt ihrer Wirkung erreichen und dann äh das so langsam losgeht, dass sich die Leute und das Virus äh irgendwie anders arrangieren und äh ja,
Ähm es wieder äh nach oben geht mit den Zahlen, wenn man dem nicht aktiv entgegenwirkt.
Genau.
Gut, jetzt seid ihr alle entlassen. Wir sagen vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Äh wir freuen uns weiterhin über die ganzen Kommentare, Tipps und Einblicke zu all den Aspekten, die wir hier genannt haben und was sonst vielleicht noch ganz interessant ist und dann hören wir uns nächste Woche wieder an.
Jawohl, tschüs.